this is Sky News 10 Britons will sell
their kidneys to this man the new face
of Moore's murder Myra Hindley back in
hospital this week and the Heart Lung
mother says happy birthday son
good evening you're watching the world
news from Sky television news on the
hour every hour and our first story this
evening ten Britons have agreed to sell
their kidneys for cash to a German [ __ ]
who plans to set up an organ transplant
business here in an exclusive interview
with Sky News at his home near Stuttgart
Kant Raney a Adelman said the donors
would have surgery in Paris and be paid
twenty thousand pounds each missus
snatcher has ordered her ministers to
look into how to stop the kidneys for
sale trade which she described as
absolutely abhorrent but count Adelman
told Sky News that he'll carry on his
business come what may we can also
reveal the count is currently under
investigation over an alleged illegal
immigration ring from Germany Richard
Ellis the small sleepy German village of
senton heart near the Swiss border is an
unlikely place for a business dealing in
the purchase and sale of human parts yet
from this modest home amid the clutter
of his ten children can Terranea Rene
Graf Adelman carries out his
controversial trade Adelman last week
caused a storm of protest in Britain by
offering up to 20,000 pounds for a
kidney now ten people from Britain have
said they want to become donors joining
hundreds of Germans on aid almonds books
within weeks
Adelman estimates at least one of the
Britons whose names he is keeping secret
at the moment will be flown to a Paris
Hospital undergo an operation and then
be sent home - a kidney but thousands of
pounds richer
he says Britons have a perfect right to
sell their kidneys despite opposition
from mrs. Thatcher it is a personal
decision in Greenwich they found out a
personal decision a Prime Minister has
not a right to say that it's all food
but if I'm missing my right arm roof and
there's someone who you know is willing
to sell his right arm to give to me yes
would you do that of course why not it
is not my decision that he will sell for
his arm and he'd make a bit of money out
of it and so be okay yes by not waiting
there if it's normal it's normal it's
not a special thing but his is his
decision to sell his arm this weekend
mrs. Thatcher is at checkers but already
alarmed at the prospect of a kidneys for
sale scandal
all administers to look at ways of
stopping what she believes is a vile
trade back in West Germany
Adelman x' activities are not only
unpopular with the german authorities
but with his neighbors to make food it's
no good it's only for money Sky News has
learned that the count a former salesman
of heavy plant machinery is under
investigation by police for allegedly
helping to smuggle illegal immigrants
into Germany Adelman freely admits being
investigated but claims he is being
persecuted we have the same authorities
in the country we had before the war
says s has only controlled two occupied
countries Germany was not controlled by
the SS it was controlled by the same
justice we have today with this new
information about the self-styled counts
activities at this house here it is
likely the British authorities will want
to take even further action to stop him
peddling his trade in Britain Richard
Ellis Sky News here an urgent appeal has
been issued to doctors to help trace the
source of a new outbreak of Legionnaires
disease in central London four people
are in hospital with the disease another
six are under observation it's close to
the scene of Britain's worst outbreak at
the BBC headquarters Broadcasting House
last year but officials don't think the
latest outbreak is connected this
outbreak began in central London but the
source has not been traced the area
under investigation includes the busy
shopping centers in Oxford Street and
Regent Street the theatre district
around the Haymarket and has a high
concentration of office blocks the five
men known to have contracted the disease
had all been here in January
an incident room has been set up at
Westminster Council offices where
officials are working agent Lee to
pinpoint the source of the infection
they're paying particular attention to
businesses with water cooling systems a
common source of Legionnaires disease
we're asking doctors who have patients
with pneumonia who have been in that
area
to contact us so that we can start the
detective work to investigate where the
patients have been and trying to
pinpoint the source of the of the
infection we have already been searching
widely of the organism sampling watering
cooling systems and instituting
disinfection wherever that seems
appropriate
last week the BBC was fined three and a
half thousand pounds in connection with
an outbreak of Legionnaires disease last
April that was traced to a water cooling
tower on the roof of Broadcasting House
but although the two outbreaks are in
the same area of London health officials
say they aren't connected jakiro Li Sky
News prison offices leaders have offered
what they describe as a peace formula in
an attempt to resolve the ones with
dispute tere McLaren of the prison
officers association said he hoped the
new proposals would find some common
ground with the home office and
contingency plans are being drawn up to
handle a possible walkout by prison
officers throughout England and Wales
the government and police have been
accused of a cover-up over the scale of
violent Anarchy which raised at ones
with prison after prison officers walked
out and police were called in last
Monday its alleged authorities battled
to keep control during a 14-hour riot in
which one prisoner threatened to slash
the throat of a governor with a broken
piece of glass the newspaper also claims
another governor was badly beaten with a
wooden chair Lake that slop buckets were
thrown at officers and that hand-to-hand
fighting between inmates armed with
broken furniture and police broke out
some believe the viciousness of what
happened inside the prison was
deliberately covered up because of fears
it would spark copycat violence the top
security jails throughout the country
thus jeopardizing the security of the
entire prison service but the Home
Office vehemently denies the accusation
a spokeswoman for the prison insists
authoritative never denied there was
trouble initially but she says the
problems did not last for 14 hours and
were not on the scale claimed the
spokeswoman adds there were a number of
minor incidents that took only half an
hour to sort out conditions inside the
prison are now reported to be calm and
the jail's governor is confident the
police are on top of the situation I
certainly can carry on in
condition and with discipline police
officers for as long as necessary and
this could be for some time yet
if prison officers are successful in
spreading strike action to jails
throughout the country the Afghanistan
capital Kabul is under martial law
tonight as the security situation
deteriorates according to the official
Soviet news agency Tass tension is
rising rapidly as the Soviet withdrawal
continues meanwhile the Soviet foreign
minister Eduard Shevardnadze
has arrived in Pakistan in a last-ditch
attempt to secure peace for the region
with the atmosphere in Afghanistan
getting worse by the moment mr.
shevardnadze is obviously anxious to
explore any possibility of preventing
the bloody conflict expected after the
Russians have left the Pakistan foreign
minister said a hopeful tone for his
meetings with his Russian visitor an
even better footing of future confidence
try to bring a peaceful solution to the
question of Afghanistan the more so as
we are on the eve of the completion of
the withdrawal Soviets pose
mr. Shevardnadze offered his best wishes
but refused to be drawn on whether he
expected the talks to actually produce
anything meanwhile diplomats have been
abandoned their embassies in Kabul in a
steady stream leaving behind a country
desperately short of food and facing
severe winter weather it remains to be
seen where the Pakistan will be able to
do anything to help mister Shevardnadze
bring peace to their troubled neighbor
as the remnants of the 115,000 Soviet
soldiers leave Afghanistan the outlook
is indeed bleak government supporters
there say they have thousands of armed
men ready to die fighting bloodshed
would seem to be inevitable bob friend
Sky News and Bob will be here with Kaye
Burley at 7 o'clock while Sky Television
has been making the news itself today
day one of the satellite revolution put
us on television and in print all over
the world dozens of journalists and
special guests attended a final briefing
before blast off just a few minutes ago
February the 5th at Sky Television began
with a tour by Rupert Murdoch of the Sky
News studios in West London and a final
check with the staff that everything was
ready for the launch then began a day of
photo calls and interviews that involved
the whole of Sky's presenting and senior
executive staff and at times threatened
to overrun the entire news desk
the visitors were shown a tape that
every customer will see in the shops
around Britain from tomorrow so how many
views did mr. Murdoch expect to get at
the launch of Sky 600,000 homes will
have sky the sky channel available to it
tonight and has had for some time and is
the British market ready for Sky were
interested building very fast and Olbia
we expect there be a shortage of dishes
in terms of the demand for many many
months years I hope many of the
questions were tough and symptomatic of
the kind of treatment the satellite
company's been receiving since the
announcement seven months ago that Sky
was to launch away from the crush mr.
Murdoch was confident that it had been
important to break the BBC ITV duopoly
well I think it's very important for
Britain
I think it's good for the viewers I
think it's good for British industry I
think it benefits everybody
now that satellite broadcasting is a
reality the debate about its future is
sure to become even more intense
Howard Foster Sky News and ke Burleigh
has been all around the world to bring
you a special programme called the
revolution it'll to be telling you
everything about satellite television
right after this news bulletins and the
two of us will be with you at breakfast
time every weekday on Sky News so if
you're an early bird and you're fed up
catching the worms then join us at 6:00
each morning for a nonstop diet of
breakfast news as it happens around the
UK and the rest of the world we look
forward to having you with us on the
sunrise program welcome it coming up in
the next part of this news from sky why
the French are even more worried about
their telephone chat lines and Moore's
murderer Myra Hindley will return to
hospital next week an exclusive report
stay with us
and welcome back sky news can
exclusively reveal that the jailed
Moore's murderer Myra Hindley will
return to hospital this week to learn if
she has cancer Hindley had minor surgery
and tests recently after complaining of
stomach pains after that rare appearance
in the outside world Sky News was able
to put together a new picture of her
showing her now is it very different
from earlier photographs this is the
face of child killer Myra Hindley today
in her 24th year behind bars it shows a
woman in middle age attractive and
carefully made up her spirit far from
broken in spite of new worries about
cancer the drawing commissioned by Sky
News is based on a detailed account of
Hindley's appearance by someone who sees
her regularly she still bears a
half-inch long scar beneath her left eye
the result of a fight with a fellow
prisoner some years ago before she was
brought to cookin wood jail in Rochester
Kent where she has spent the last few
years ten days ago Hindley now 46 was
taken to nearby All Saints Hospital in
Chatham for a laparotomy operation an
inspection of the abdomen often carried
out to investigate suspected tumors on
that occasion she was escorted into the
public Miriam ward by three prison
waters while police kept guard outside
before other patients realized who she
was she was whisked away in the back of
a prison car her head covered with a
blanket but most of them would have had
trouble recognizing Hindley compared to
her old photographs she has changed
dramatically gone are the rebel looks
and the bleached blond hair she had back
in 1966 when with her partner in crime
Ian Brady she was jailed for life for
the Moors Murders two years ago please -
her back to the Lancashire Moors where
she buried her victims in the search for
more bodies these days she's learned to
conform studying open university courses
in psychology working as a trustee in
the prison stores and awaiting along for
parole date Martyn brunt Sky News chat
line firms are today considering suing
British Telecom over its decision to
pull the plug from noon tomorrow on
their controversial and lucrative gossip
services parents have been saddled with
huge bills run up by their talkative
children but in France the problem
far worse their dating services are
raking in even bigger profits and there
are complaints that they're being used
as a front for prostitution and a cover
for murder this is Audrey and she's
become pretty familiar to the telephone
subscribers of France in the past few
weeks she and others like her are all
part of the service if you have a phone
over here
the French have grasped new technology
with both hands to develop the most
sociable phone system in Europe it's
called mini tell a home computer
connected to your telephone free of
charge and depending on your point of
view ready to open up a whole new world
or bring the unwanted attentions of
strangers into your house with mini tell
you can book a flight or a train and
even do your shopping
but the fastest-growing minitel service
is this it's called the massager eros
and it's for the adult customer who
wants to open up a few more intimate
lines of communication at home I can
hold risque conversations with any
number of subscribers assisted by Audrey
salomi Amandine or just plain sexy I've
typed in my pseudonym now I've decided
to speak to one of the customers called
Claire so I've been a sent her a message
and reply comes up within seconds no one
who uses this system has ever really
meant to meet but it does happen and at
least one person has been lured to his
death through using mini tale like this
a man was murdered after he agreed to a
meeting with a couple he did not know
his killers used the message service to
promised favors that they had no
intention of giving him despite the
on-screen warnings this service is
worrying French parents they're
increasingly demanding that the
telephone companies fix security locks
to the keyboards apart from anything
else and now with Audrey and her friends
will cost you almost 60 pounds Howard
Foster Sky News here the Labour Party
has published a list of the 300
hospitals around the country which it's
claimed are earmarked for opting out
from the National Health Service the
list drawn up by the shadow health
minister Harriet Harman is Labour's
first step in a campaign to save the NHS
from what they say is a slow death under
the Torres the MP zone major local
hospital said Thomas's is on the labour
list along with 300 others according to
Labour that will only leave small local
hospitals directly under health service
control depriving patients of easily
available specialist care for many
problems we want to show people that
their own district General Hospital on
which they've come to rely is marked by
the government for opting out of the
health service and that unless they are
admitted as an accident or in a case of
emergency they won't necessarily be able
to get treatment in their own local
hospital health secretary Kenneth Clarke
has already rejected what he calls
Labour's irresponsible scares and the
government insists opted-out hospital
trusts will still be part of the NHS
those self-governing for improved
efficiency and that all hospitals will
continue to provide essential core
services however many hospitals opt out
in the end it'll be a slow process full
legislation won't be in place until next
year at the earliest
but already Labour's anxious to do
everything it can to fight what the
party sees as first steps by the
government to destroy
than reform the NHS Adam Bolton Sky News
coming up after the break all the
sporter spot of weather and happy
birthday Jonathan a little boy they said
could never be born
don't go away
and if you've just joined is a very good
evening and welcome along to the start
up transmissions from Sky Television now
a young Bradford man who survived five
years after a heart-lung operation is
celebrating a game this time her baby
son Jonathan's first birthday surgeons
advise Debbie Leonard that her pregnancy
was dangerous but she took the risk with
the happiest of results Debbie Leonard
has more to smile about today than most
people born with a hole in the heart
condition she survived massive surgery
to put her own life on the line and
become the world's first heart-lung
transplant mum it was the top surgeon
magda Jakub who carried out the
pioneering heart and lung transplant the
operation at her field hospital saved
Debbie's life then two years ago Debbie
discovered she was pregnant doctors
warned her there were serious risks
involved no other transplant patient had
ever given birth the strain of having
the baby might kill her
the first reaction was say oh dear and
then I told them that was determined to
have the baby
I really did want it if I'm a transplant
I couldn't do any exercise I could
barely walk up the stairs I certainly
won't have had a baby probably wouldn't
have been here what about the future
what you want now see Jonathan grow up
whatever the future holds today's
birthday celebration is a milestone not
only in Jonathan's very short life but
also for Debbie as she remembers it's
another year since doctors gave her a
second chance at the miracle of life it
all depends on you oh then your attitude
as to how long you you survived I can't
foresee you down any sooner than anybody
else it's a lot to do with your state of
mind and what your state of mind well I
hope I'm gonna be here in another 50
years okay nobody knows how long they're
going to live well now we're going after
sport and the man who is to sport what
Dobbin is to horse-racing at Lawrence
there's no answer to that and you're not
getting one penny we start with football
and a goal from Brian McClair gave
Manchester United victory over Spurs
traffic this afternoon it finished
Manchester United one tottenham nil the
United move up to fifth place in
Division one eleven points behind the
leaders arsenal one other game today in
Division two Swindon three Oxford nil
the Oxford captain Colin green all was
sent off in that match
Great Britain scored six tries as they
crushed France 30 points to eight in the
Rugby League test in Avignon today the
Welsh winger Phil Ford scored two of
them so too did captain Ellie Hanley
Castle Birds Kevin ward was named man of
the match Sweden has a new Davis Cup
hero tonight playing without villain de
and Edie Berg it was left to Michael
Byrne fors to overcome the Italians
today Byrne force beat Massimiliano Nadu
Qi in a marathon five set singles match
to give his team an unbeatable 3-1 lead
that's it more sport in an hour
Alistair well I think Penny's got the
weather for us have you been well
exactly
I thought leaping yeah well there's
still no sign of any cold weather yet
the satellite sequence that we've got
shows various bands of cloud moving
southeast Woods across the country out
in the Atlantic there's a lot of thin
cloud and some showers all moving
towards the British Isles so we could be
in for more unsettled weather there'll
be some rain over southern England
tonight but this should clear by morning
central England and Wales will be mostly
dry with a touch of ground frost in
sheltered parts Ireland and Scotland
will have showers while in the far north
of Scotland it'll be very windy tomorrow
the south will be dry with some sunshine
the North will again be windy and a
little cooler with occasional blustery
showers the temperatures a little above
average for the time of year 45 degrees
Fahrenheit in the north while the south
will be basking in a cozy 50 degrees
continuing the very mild winter so far
and the outlook is for more unsettled
weather although still mild with a
little rain in the east and the south
and that's it thanks very much indeed
penny well coming up next on Sky News
the revolution all you need to know
about the most exciting changes ever to
happen in British television we'll be
back in ten minutes to update you with
all the main stories you've been
watching the start up transmissions from
Sky News and Sky television
stay with us